hey guys and welcome to a brand new
video today I'm gonna be making a
comprehensive tutorial for GE tracker
I've got a lot of questions about this
recently so I thought maybe making a
long full video budget would be useful
for some people now before I get started
g tracker is a sponsor of mine and I've
never really explained this very much
but I am sponsored not on a per video
basis but sponsored on a referral basis
so there's a referral link in the
description I get paid from referrals so
I don't actually have to make a certain
amount of videos or anything about this
but still it is a paid promotion so just
be aware of that okay so to start off
here the flip finder tab is very going
to be using G track of the most there's
a bunch of different tabs to go through
suggested items favorite items GE Limits
highest margin new items high volume
items and the tag list so on any of
these tabs you're going to be greeted
with a very similar table is gonna start
with the item name the current price of
approximate offer price and sell phrase
the approximate profit your return on
your investment and buying and selling
quantities the buy sell ratio and the GE
limit now to go over the Slom or the
approximate offer price and sell prices
are just I'm still not quite sure how
Louis buddy tracks what is a buying sell
price I've tried quite a few times to
ask from people about it it does work
fairly well it's not 100% accurate the
only way I could imagine it determining
what is a Buy and whether they sell
because in one transaction someone's
always buying it and selling it the only
way I could imagine it working is if you
have an item at GE and it hasn't sold
and someone goes and buys it insta buys
it that counts as a buy if someone has a
buy offer in the GE and someone goes and
insta sells it that counts as a sell I'm
not sure if I always buddy can track
that but I honestly have no other clue
how might work the approximate profit is
just based on these two numbers it
should almost always be the difference
between these two the return on your
investment is just your approximate
profit divided by the current price
which gives you pretty much the right
number there that is just the ratio on
how much money you're getting back based
on how much you're investing the bank
quantity in selling quantity per hour is
pretty self-explanatory that is how many
are law
for hours so there's about 30 logged an
hour and it determined that 12 of those
are buy/offers and 19 of those are cell
offers the by cell ratio is just kind of
a variant of the ROI and the GE limit is
the limit on the G can't really explain
that anymore and this is if you favor
that the item or not so now the main
benefit of the suggested item page is
that it is a self curated list it's
gonna pull items from your favorite or
not from your favorite but from the
highest margin high-volume
G limits and possibly new items and it
gives you a list of items that most
people won't be able to see if you hit
the refresh button you're gonna get a
different list of items so if we see at
the top right now is the Eldar mall if
we refresh it go ahead and click highest
margin it's gonna be samurai boots now
so it's a bit different every time and
it is actually useful for finding more
unique clips to yourself next up is e
favorite items to have however I'm going
to skip that temporarily just to explain
a couple of things first
now the GE limits tab is mainly useful
for figuring out literally how much
profit you can get from the item and
whether it's worth it based on how much
money you're investing as right now the
way this actually sort is based on each
potential profit so if you look here at
that side the estimated profit is
actually highest for the AMIA of glory
for even though the margins only 122
versus like say they dragon pickaxe or
something else with a higher margin the
main reason here is it just takes the
actual GE limit into account so yes
you're only gonna under in point you on
each a meal of glory but since the limit
is very high for this item it's ten
thousand your potential profit is 1.2
mil and also lists the full buy price
for to buy the entire buy limit here so
it'd be 215 mil to buy ten thousand a
meal of glory fours and you can see the
profit here would be 1.2 mil you can
even use this to figure out your own
return on investment or buying ratio or
whatever you want to call it once you
get a little bit more money up to you
like a hundred mil it's a lot more
useful to find items that have medium
margins but very high limits like items
like this where you can actually get 1.2
mil profit just from flipping 10,000 of
them it doesn't take a ton of money to
do it but it's very quick not so much on
the amulet for Ben or
glory 6 or something like that next up
we have the highest margin tab and this
is when you really want to start using
your item filters so where the item
filters are is in this top right corner
here all you have to do is click the
button and it's gonna bring up a item
list here actually it looks like I
already had a filter on so we'll take
that off quickly so what this does is
actually filter items based on a
criteria you put any complete in
multiple or just one so let's say you
only had 20 mil or let's say let's do 10
mil actually 10 mil so now it's gonna
filter out any items that cost more than
10 mil now there are a bunch of
different filters that you can do but I
find the most useful ones is a price
maximum as well as filtering these
buying quantity and selling quantities
so let's say you don't want to do a
super slow item you'd go here come into
the filters it opens up there we go and
you're selling quantity minimum and
buying quantity minimum let's say you
put in five that's a pretty safe bet and
you'll be able to buy at least a couple
in one hour so once we save those
filters it's filtering out anything that
doesn't have at least five buying and
selling quantity so now we're looking at
the region bracelet now you can actually
filter items on most of these pages but
I find it most useful on the highest
margin page because a lot of people just
come here look the highest margin and I
was put in a blind offer for whatever it
is
okay the next page here is the new items
page I have very useful actually when
new items come out there's a time that
you don't even really think about I'm
pretty sure it's still extrapolate this
from the OS buddy database so you should
actually get pretty much all the new
items in the game as so this is for the
fossil Island update there's wyvern
village look we have a look at some of
the random items like soul accept cap
giant seaweed calcite driftnet oak
birdhouse like everything's here even
stuff you'd never even know about it's
very useful especially when I do my
1-hour flipping challenges for a new
content it's hard to actually keep track
of all the new items so next up another
very useful tab is the high volume tab
now this is going to filter out anything
that doesn't have at least 5000 buying
or selling quantity as its going to put
the highest GP profit item first so it's
gonna be filtering based on the
potential profit and not anything to do
with the limit although most of these
will have a limit associated with them
cause they're pretty common flips and
look I'm literally almost everyone's
there except for egg I don't know why
the egg is here get that away so you
have to take all of these high-volume
items of the grain of salt you're never
gonna want to just actually straight-up
use the margin that shows in GE tracker
because it's in movement so quickly it's
never going to be right you're better
off just looking for the items there and
then going and checking the margin
sometimes it moves around so quickly you
might not even be a good margin but
let's say 380 and we're selling it for
349 then it's a really good margin
actually I'll just do that while I'm
making the video [__] it 10k and we'll
come back to that later yeah so you can
see it's actually really useful for
finding high-volume items even if the
margin is never gonna be right you can
filter on this item page as well but I
don't really find it to be as useful
because mainly you're just gonna be
looking at these top items once it gets
into zero they're gonna there's gonna be
like one or two GP margin at that point
anyway and the last appear is the item
tag list now this is just a different
way of filtering a bunch of items though
it's very useful for me because I often
do items based on category but let's say
you just want to quickly look at all of
the medium blue rewards there you go all
104 medium clear rewards it's useful for
other aspects that's not not even
including flipping let's say just want
to look at the most valuable item you
can get from a medium clue scroll Ranger
boots wizard boots holy sandals things
just can kind of keep looking blue
rewards should encompass all items so we
can look here at the most expensive clue
reward item right now the third age
pickaxe he's ever even trade in the game
and I'll know I've never seen one before
there's only a couple traded every day
at most and they have all the bosses
here as well as raids and new PvP things
and there's just kind of useful thing to
have a look through and now last up is
actually the favorited items tab now I
actually have a completely different use
for this tab and it's not what you think
I see if you have a look let's go back
to the highest margin tab for a second
here if you notice the worst let's look
at the worst margin here it's actually
2.5 however this is based on the fact
that the buy offer is lower than the
sell offer occasionally
get swapped and for whatever reason it's
gonna show with a negative number
now it's essentially just as say
something has a negative 300k margin
it's still 8/3 Newark a margin just OS
buddy has messed up the numbers and
hence is not going to be showing it on
this highest margin pet tab however if
we go to the favorited items tab you're
gonna probably have nothing there to
begin with
however if you start favoriting like
literally every item you see like I have
like I have 500 items favorited I
believe I can notice that there's gonna
be different margins here that are not
gonna be showing up on any of these tabs
which is actually extremely useful and I
would recommend doing so let's look at
Diaa let's say the armadale hilt not
gonna show up in any of these tabs
because technically it has a negative
200k margin which is just it doesn't
matter and you can see here maybe we
could buy for twenty two point six and
sell it for twenty two point nine tons
of options here and that's why I would
really recommend favoring a bunch of
items to have a look at and you can
actually make your own list of items
literally nobody else will have access
to the way I do it is normally on the
highest margin page whenever there's
some new items here you can just hit add
to favor it's easy to do
hopefully the mods don't kill me and
this doesn't crash the website if so I
may have to change this okay so now
we've gone over all of the flip finder
tabs now we're gonna have a look at an
actual item so here is the samurai gods
or let's look at it why not first item
in here so to start off here you pretty
much have all the information that you
had on the graph form except it's just
laid out a bit differently it'll also
show you the high alko what is kind of
nice now this is a new feature here it
has a previous price data so you can see
every 10 minutes right it's 20 minutes
in this case it's going to be updating
with what the price was at if you leave
it open and I'll keep it live updating
as well so start off here a new feature
that God added to GE tracker is since
buddy will very frequently leg out on GE
tracker they've added their own price
graph that will be as a backup or a
contingency if OS buddy is not working
so this thing here means that we're
pulling item directly from the OS buddy
database which is generally going to be
much more up-to-date and accurate
however if there is a tracker symbol
here means the database is down is gonna
be showing you a little more dumbed down
but fairly accurate
price graph there but I wouldn't be
taking it as seriously if for some
reason they always buddy symbol is not
here so we're and start off with a
full-on view of the graph here and this
is going to be defaulted on to the month
so just gonna show you the last month
and the average price every day of what
the items at a very useful feature here
is actually these little letters here
which are going to show you updates to
the game so let's see the exam records
where it's shot up pretty much after is
the well probably this update here maybe
I'm not sure why it's actually going up
so much it's hard to tell just based on
the update name but probably has
something to do with the other godsword
getting change the Bandos godsword spec
is getting reduced to 50% or at least is
pulled to have that happen okay the
start off here gonna make sure you have
the split graph feature turned on you
can't really notice it so much here but
if you gotten to say the week here and
you have the split graph off you can see
it's only going to show you an average
between the buys and sell offers so
that's why you're gonna always want to
have it on if you could here to the day
graph it's gonna show you even more a
difference between what to buy and sell
offers or at so one other feature that's
really useful is the ten minute graph
under the options here is these are
gonna say ten minute or 30 minutes gonna
be based on what you have turned on 30
minute graph is gonna show you less
intervals but I find this a little bit
less buggy however if you turn it to the
10 minute graph it's gonna show you
updates every 10 minutes if there are at
them which is gonna be a little bit more
accurate but it's really not necessary
to have on I just kind of like it now of
course over here you have the different
time frames you can look at the most
recent data you can look at is on the
day graph it's gonna show you 24 hours a
week is gonna show you a week a month is
gonna show you a month quarter is gonna
be three months I believe and a year is
gonna be a full year which is good for
looking at historical prices of items
and can be useful for future predictions
if you scroll down a little bit now you
can see the amount traded birthday which
is extremely useful so if you have it
set to the month each one of these data
points is going to be a day so it's
pretty useful to have it on the month
because you can see how many are traded
on average in a day and so let's say
samurai cod swords have about 400 I
traded the day these guys 400 here at
360 you can see how many on average of
there are I figured out into the day
graphs gonna show you much more
accurately in the last hour
even so you can see between 11:00 and
11:30 there's about three BOTS and three
sold back a little further is nineteen
and you can see pretty much exactly how
much you expect to buy and sell in an
hour which is especially useful for me
when I'm doing my 1-hour buying
challenges if you come down here a
little bit further these are just
different things you can set up for one
price alerts which I've messed around
with a little bit here you can set
alerts for when a certain data point
goes below or above a certain point and
you can get an SMS text or an email
that's let's say I'm not gonna add text
for this but let's say you want the
profit margin when it's above 100k you
can people do numbers hundred thousand I
send me an email when that happens and
it does however of course it's going to
only alert you once the actual dad has
updated so you might not always get your
email right on time I'd say the most
important thing to take away from this
is to make sure using the day graph I
set it to ten minutes if you want and
make sure you have the split graph
feature on and you're looking at you buy
and selling quantities okay and one last
thing to mention around flip finding is
going to be actually in your account
settings if you come over here to
account settings now you will actually
be able to flip on a free play mode if
you're for whatever reason you're only
wanting to look at say free play items
there's actually a button in here that
will switch it over to free to play for
you so it's just gonna be right here at
the bottom here and you're gonna tick it
on if you want to only see free-to-play
items it's gonna work for almost all of
the flipping tabs however it won't work
for your favorite items abs will work
for highest margin high volume as well
as for some of the money-making tabs I
believe it works as well okay so
speaking of that we have a huge other
section here which is money-making
there's a ton of different things here
we need to be speeding through these
ones a little bit more so let's start
here with the high alchemy pretty
self-explanatory it's just going to be
finding margins between buy offers and
the high out price it's a little bit of
a crapshoot I would focus more on
finding breakeven items that net you
experience more so than trying to out
for profit however you can occasionally
find really hilarious items that you can
get like a 10k margin on so what you're
kind of looking for more here's if
you're scrolling through the pages
you're looking for something with a
limit higher than 70 because 70 Alex is
gonna take
like three minutes so you're really
gonna want something with a tire buying
quantity and air bottle subs disappear
theoretically it could be nadine 13 GPA
on each one and which mainly it just is
that you're breaking even and it has a
buying limit of 14,000 Firebaugh saves
here as well 3,000 and I would keep
looking a little further and you might
find even some more useful items next up
is a potion decanter tool and the one
thing I don't really find too useful
about this tool is the fact that it
seems to sort based on the cheapest dose
however the cheapest dose is usually not
a great idea so by anti-fire potion ones
are gonna take like forever you're
almost always gonna want to buy a dose
threes now I'm not really sure if
there's a way to change that but don't
see any way to do it so really what
you're gonna want to do here is just use
those threes to decamp potions but there
is still some uses here for one it does
actually show you dose threes and it
just gives you a list of full potions
here and what the margins could be and
usually they are somewhat tied together
between the different doses so if you
can can be worth to actually go ahead
and look at the margins for these items
if you have no clue what I'm talking
about here I'll leave a link in the
description for a tutorial for this next
up here we have a herb lower profit tab
now finally most useful tool here is the
unfinished potion because that is
generally the most ideal way to make
profit from herb or you're not getting
any experience here but this is
basically turning herbs with a vial into
an unfinished potion you can look here
for the most expensive ocean here it
looks like unfinished snapdragons are at
the time pretty useful and that
time-saving to actually just look at
this tool instead of checking them all
yourself however you definitely can't
just do that as well next up on the
herbal or thing you have making potions
now this isn't really for profit but you
can see which potions cost the least to
make and it can kind of help you
determine how you want to train her
Bloor also you have a clean herb thing
but I wouldn't ever recommend clean
herbs it's just a pain in the ass it's
not worth it the next step is probably
the most important tool in this
money-making section it's really more of
a flippin tool and that is the item sets
and crafting page now what this does is
it pulls most items in the game that can
be transformed into other items based on
crafting based on making sets
any any item that you can change quickly
into another one so let's say this item
here the ancestral robe set if you went
ahead and bought all the individual
pieces and combined them to a set you
could potentially make 1.5 mil off this
item if you scroll down here more the
malediction more wood can be created
with three shard pieces in a volcano
somewhere primer will do boots can be
created with level 555 runecrafting
if you use a primordial crystal on a
dragon boot at crafting amulets of
theory and it just kind of keeps going
and shows you a ton of different item
combinations is even to show you
repairing barrows items which you buy
gustin's helm zero and you repair it
into a gustin's helm
they didn't even 85k this is probably
the most useful tab in the money-making
section by far so next up is the Barrows
repair tab essentially what this is is a
tool that shows you the differences
between a completely used up gustin's
helm 0 and the defens helm right now
that's probably a hundred and fifty k
difference or something like that
because it cost like 60 to 100 K to
repair items it shows you the
approximate profit after the repair so
you don't even have to calculate
anything up here you can select if
you're using an armor stand or using the
NPC if you select NPC it's going to show
you a different price if you're using
the armor stand you can pop in your RS n
or I think you can just put in a number
next up we have a more of a convenience
tab here which is e magic tablets which
basically just shows you the most
profitable tablet to make at the moment
which is pretty useful just to quickly
look at before you go ahead and check
every single tablet yourself so it looks
like the alembert's teleport is giving
you the highest profit right now and it
also shows you a buying and selling
quantity which is kind of nice
next up we have a tan leather thing
another pretty convenience tab here but
you can also select a tan leather lunar
option here which will give you a more
anchor breakdown of if you're using the
lunar spell book to tan aldehydes next
up we have a plank making tab which you
can either select
making planks from a sawmill or using
the lunar spell book again very
somewhere but still useful to see what
the potential profit is and that this
tab is probably the least useful the
nightmares own reward point it's pretty
obvious which one you actually want to
pick the profit per points is one and
anything else is less than 0.2
pretty well and that's pretty much it
for all of the tools that G trekker has
to offer and now I'm not really gonna go
over the profit tracker here because
it's not really anything to help you
actually flip better it's more of just
to keep track of your profits obviously
now the last feature of GE tracker I
want to go over is the merchant in logs
section it's under the leaderboard tab
here is very useful for looking at what
other people are flipping now all you
have to do is click on View merge log
and it's going to show you exactly what
items they flipped the quantity and the
profit they got on top of that it will
show you the date as well as the
progress here it's a really good tool
for looking at what items are actually
working and what other people are doing
to actually make profit from flipping
all right guys that is pretty much it I
know this is a long video but I had a
ton of questions regarding G's racket
recently I thought it would be useful to
just go over the entire thing so thanks
for watching all the way through if you
did guys if you enjoyed it don't forget
to toss a video a like and I will see
you in the next video